[Music]
8:14 13 1697 5 the early morning in
Wisconsin and the airwaves crackle with
the sound of division he's fighting for
us you know and he's don't like it is
and he tends to use this Twitter account
way too much but he is trying very hard
and he is working very hard to sort of
the people around him do we want to live
in a country Gerry Boehner is the
conservative radio host out of step with
his listeners he can't stand trial free
world gets into petty arguments they all
seem to love him at least if an hour
co-hosting his show is anything to go by
I'm interested to know what you feel
about how you voted and whether you
voted the right way the wrong way I
really had no choice it was the lesser
of two evils I certainly was not going
to give a vote to Hillary Clinton
there's a lot of people in Britain who
think that Donald Trump is a narcissist
a bully he's fighting for us removing
some of the regulation and and he's
kicking Isis's butt out there and and
about he's doing a great job you sound
pretty angry about yes tell with nothing
but disrespect and you know I understand
that he's not perfect but he's trying
very hard if there was an election on
November the 8th 2017 you still vote for
Trump in a second in a heartbeat and
would be pushing for everyone else to do
two things
the Gerry Boehner show Gerry admits he's
not winning the argument I share their
anger I share the absolute incompetence
that's happened in Washington but by
Republicans but it seems for the core
Trump voter and I don't know how far
beyond that that anger is enough and the
fight is enough and you heard that and
call after call after call
but Wisconsin is a big place we set off
to test the climate in this bellwether
state a year on from the election it
soon becomes obvious it's still about as
polarized as you can get in the rural
South I stopped off to meet Allen
trainin a third-generation farmer he had
grave reservations about Trump a year
ago and he's nothing but contempt for
the president now I think he's an ass a
jerk he and his wife Angie are in
despair it's so deeply embarrassing I
think it's I think that the status of
the United States in the world has
plummeted like we're not that Ally that
you can trust Allen's hayrides are a
favorite here but there's a rule don't
talk about politics it's too toxic too
full of hate and no fun anymore he says
his visitors agree since Trump's
election politics have divided friends
even close relatives it's hard to talk
to other people family I'm worried about
Thanksgiving and how that's gonna go of
talking politics of different sides it's
very divisive very separate
[Music]
you don't have to go far to find the
political extremes on show here on the
main street of a town called Marshfield
we found these evangelical Christians
making their pro-life protests quietly
but starkly 15 percent of Wisconsin's
Christians are evangelical and 80
percent of them back trump a significant
vote for a president who hasn't always
displayed the most Christian behavior
later that evening
after prayers they explain why they
decided Trump was their man and they saw
Donald Trump is kind of a John Wayne the
kind of a guy who really was an outsider
who was going to stand up and push back
in and try to get something done where
they're sick and tired of this two-party
system that isn't getting anywhere so I
think a lot of people realized that
maybe Donald Trump isn't the second
coming of Jesus but he's a guy it's
going to stand up and fight for what
they believe are their values which is
Liberty first Dave David Meyer is a
former football coach who now travels
the Midwest rallying his born-again base
you'll tolerate Donald Trump's
unchristian behavior if he delivers what
you want to deliver well we're all first
of all we're all sinners saved by grace
I have a lot of unchristian behavior in
my background as well he's been the most
Christian president in the policies that
has extended than any president in my
lifetime if not in his own behavior if
not in his own behavior that's right
but delivering for the Christian Right
may not be that easy for Trump even if
he wanted to
Trump's election success and the march
of the right has left many Democrats in
despair here in Wisconsin and across
America a new movement of the left is
mobilizing its aim resistance to almost
everything Trump does myself and a lot
of friends I talked to felt very
helpless they wanted to do something to
make sure that people weren't hurt in
their country in a Wisconsin coffee shop
the resistance is being led here by two
women plotting an anti Trump anti right
insurgency to the rest of the nation
that's very unsettling the weapons of
war our traditional protest but also
carefully targeted campaigns against
Congress men and women backing policies
they dislike members of Congress have
been inundated with phone calls their
voicemail is full
can't really do anything else except
answer their phones or they just stop
answering their phones and they don't
pay attention to their constituents but
in vast areas of the place they call the
Dairyland state where cattle and cheese
are an 80 billion dollar industry the
political scrap between right and left
is a world away from the rural reality
nothing that's more important than
theory this is our backbone it's a very
traditional I mean you know do things
change yes there was a time when we had
what people like Ken Heyman care about
here is what Trump can do for them I'll
deal with the talk if you can walk the
walk and what I mean by that is if I can
deal with all the things that are said
about him about everything if if it
comes out that it's the best for the
people if business is doing well and the
country is doing well then I can deal
with the talk in these parts they went
overwhelmingly for Trump the non
politician who's torn up the Washington
rulebook and says what he thinks so what
you seem to be saying Ken if Trump
delivers you'll back him again yes yes
if he delivers and we don't you know we
can see where we're the best of the best
is for for the majority of the people
then that's what it takes
for well over a century they've been
making cheese here lots of it it's a
skill passed down through generations a
tradition that thrives it's the state's
pride its history its way of life they
know what they're doing and in politics
as in cheese they know what they want I
like that he's very authoritative he
does what he want what he what he feels
is right for the people and by the
people and he's his own man and I think
that really takes the rest of them guys
off
she's even beginning to persuade her
previously anti-trump colleagues he
would like people to work he doesn't
want people to get their money off the
society that's why I think Wisconsin
border for Trump because we're
hard-working people it sounds to me like
you're becoming a bit of a fan could be
could be yeah winning you over and
that's the unmistakable message from the
factories and the farms of Wisconsin's
dairy land the workers here back Trump a
year ago and still back in now you're
prepared to give Trump a chance oh yes
all of us are I mean because you know we
got to try something it's not been
working to stay at a school has been for
how many years we got to do something
what you realize coming to rural
Wisconsin is that all the noise around
Donald Trump the fighting the sackings
the tweeting the unpresidential behavior
it doesn't mean anything all they care
about here is that he's not a career
politician he's trying to do things
differently and a year on they're still
prepared to give him a chance
so Wisconsin indeed America remains
bitterly divided over a president
without precedent
those who detest him still do those who
back Trump are standing by him for them
it's about business the economy and jobs
but their support comes with a warning
Trump has to deliver or he'll be swept
away on the very tide that carried him
to the White House Mark Austin Sky News
in Wisconsin